[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your
mother that is not your mother looking
at it now we're trying to get to Jamaica
all so
simp don't worry Chum's got you so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought you name was chump yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
listen chump what did you just call me
I'm sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
[Music]
what this isn't about migration it's
about
Adventure w w wo wo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
[Music]
trouble what
isange what
tange it's you with laange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and we
w
when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable me you eat you I'm
kidding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
go
he